welcome to a day plus real talk the
killing of Zimbabwe Cecil some
successful the line an American dentist
pay fifty five thousand dollars to hunt
Cecil using a bow and arrow it turns out
those who facilitate the hunt illegally
lured the popular cat out of the
sanctuary now the dentist is in
everybody's crosshairs joining me now is
my good friend Towanda from our context
team upstairs he's from Zimbabwe so
Towanda who do you feel bad for now the
dentist or the cat I'm sorry to say none
of the above because the conversation of
a conservation of endangered species is
goes much further in as much as much
broader than the fate of an individual
lion or the carrier of an individual
dentist there's a tendency you know
whenever something like this happens for
people to just focus on the anecdote
look at the one pain so right right now
with so the lion he is the rallying
cry cry for everybody but what's
actually happening is that we are
looking at an industry that is existed
for is for four centuries this is this
is the poaching industry right or other
or the gaming it was the industry is at
the call the line is very thin between
the trophy hunting industry and the
poaching industry which is organized
crime trophy hunting is served as a
facade for for poachers okay of the
longest time people like the dentist
come to Zimbabwe Namibia and other
hunting destinations they pay the token
fee which is supposed to be the trophy
fee and once they leave the camp nobody
knows what they should nobody knows
whether the animals they are shooting on
the designated quarter for trophy
hunting right or whether they are
protected animals like sisal in this
case are people in Zimbabwe as concerned
as it seems like to meet the rest of the
international community well I Cecil I'm
sorry just leaving right now like Cecil
lives matters but start trending I not
really I think that's just an internet
sensation that is separate from the
actual conservation debate and the
conversation of you know the
preservation of endangered species right
so whatever you see on the internet
today I think is not relevant to the
conservation efforts that people are
actually making on the ground do you
think it's fair for the dentist to be
increased by the way he's been like you
doing hunting that I don't think so I
think he deserves a
a trial like every other poacher poacher
why you gotta put your 100 anybody who
kills and endangered species that's not
a designated trophy is is a poacher so
illegal hunting is poaching and that's
basically what you did thanks so much
man appreciate you comin on right now
thanks guys that's what we have for this
week we'll keep it here like the Real
Talk aj+ for more news and videos and
stories look us up on Facebook Twitter
YouTube Instagram or download the app
I'll see you guys next week
you